[music]
good morning died welcome to the
panel discussion technology
sovereignty in materials
science as part of the berlins 1 way 2021 which was organized by
the berlin research alliance
50 a fairly newly
founded interest group of the
foreign minister research institutes in
berlin we will take you on an
informative but hopefully  also an
entertaining journey to technological
sovereignty we want to shed light on its importance in the world of
the role of materials science as a
key technology and in particular
the potential of the location
berlin let
me introduce myself briefly i am
the tour guide the
moderator at this point my name is
thomas  schröder head of the
leibniz institute for crystal growth in
berlin here combined with a
professorship in physics at the humboldt university
but the real reason why i hold this
position here now is that he is also
the speaker of the leibniz strategy
forum  technological sovereignty in
which we
want to make the potential of leibniz diapers visible
and of course also
want to make them connectable to the outside world and leibnitz is
particularly exciting we are
interdisciplinary we have
natural sciences social sciences
and economics and so
i would also like to briefly refer to our
highly owns the panel  come in
and start a little round of introductions at that point
we divided it into three
blocks economics and politics
ie we were able to win
marcell fritzsche maybe you can say a couple of sentences about yourself and your
background yes good morning my
name is my name is  marseille
fraczek head of the german institute for
economic research in berlin we are
many name said
economic research institute but also
interdisciplinary also have 15
between panel also sociologists
political scientists psychologists and yes my
own research agenda or
research interest relates
primarily to the topic of european
integration and also
distribution effects and interaction
between social
scientists economy is many thanks to the the second colleague in this blog is
mr engelbert bayer from bmwf who i
can't see in the stream yet,
that means we hope that
joins us right away then is the second
block trading of innovation networks
in materials research and i am
very happy that we
can win ms ursula holl mr byers is coming
to us then maybe
you can hear us
for a second excellent a warm greeting
thank you very much for
joining us and we are just
introducing it it would be nice if
you could say a couple of words about yourself
and your position
yes you have become an angel bavarian
i am in charge of the applied
research for innovations sub-department  in the
Federal Ministry of Education and
Research  ng for a few years
before that, i was involved in
strategic planning in
high-tech strategy for many years
, my
area of responsibility also includes the exciting topic of mater
als research, on which we will have many projects in the comin
years, so no
only that, thank you so much today
we come to the second block as
already announced innovation
networks material research and we are pleased
that we
were able to win from the fraunhofer
gesellschaft
[music]
works
so i am the
business building materials components
materials and the danish from 16 years
now worked at the fraunhofer
gesellschaft before the  current position
responsible for strategic
management in one of our institutes in
darmstadt and from there i also want to watch today
and was
interested in aspects
ok thank you very much then we come to the
participants at the point of the
third block and that's about
berlin as a center
to position itself more strongly for materials research
, and i am pleased that
ms
want to further develop berlin
institutionally and also in terms of content and
that is why i am on the one hand
following on from mr fratzscher
interdisciplinarity is the great
opportunity in berlin due to the density and
variety of institutions so that
now
as president of humboldt university
my aim is to find the right
institutional form for this
finding and supporting colleagues in the
institutes that we have well-
functioning networks and
infrastructures in which this is
also possible i have been doing such managerial tasks for 20 years
and if
so from my basic training  Her
hydraulic engineer, thank you very much and
then I am pleased that we have been able to win
Ms. Jutta Koch from Berlin politics under
very. Ms. including very
has been responsible for a few years in
the
non-university research department currently in
the Berlin Senate Chancellery for a number of years
is how this connection will
develop the next few weeks
we will show that we don't know yet in the
context of the expensive government formation we
have a very strong
non-university research slomka in berlin which is
becoming ever stronger and also acts more and more
cooperatively and one has
direct and cooperative with the other
means that we particularly
like to have differentiated cooperation with our renowned
universities
but
look beyond national borders I
look forward to the next opportunity
for sale prohibited then we will start
right away in the first block we
will always do it like this  we
get a little impulse and then
this can be discussed and the
next speaker
will be in the context of this block and yes I look forward to the
contribution of higher mass Fratzscher at
this point, who can
certainly explain to us why the
term technology sovereignty is
becoming increasingly important  in this
world
yes i would like to introduce from my perspective of the
economist economics
science that the topic of
sovereignty wants to introduce technological sovereignty
and maybe say something
hopefully not destructive thesis
that technological sovereignty
can be thought of nationally or
locally but actually always only globally
in which of course different regions are
different  science centers like
the science center berlin can make a very
decisive contribution
and the point why or there are four
reasons why i am convinced that
the topic of technological sovereignty should be considered
globally  must even if it
can and
must be helped to shape locally the first
reason is the topic of research and
development and the complexity of
many technological developments in particular
requires many
networks to build a network woman synthetic resin addressed locally
but also internationally and globally
important typical example development
the vaccines
many say bayern tag the vaccine
or the first vaccine was developed in
the usa it was developed by pfizer and when
you see how such a substance is being
developed and tested
you realize you really need a certain
size, a certain scalability and
that often just requires one  global
perspective global cooperation and is
one of the examples the second also
again on the complexity is the
supply chains how products
technologies are manufactured and
here too we are realizing very painfully at the
moment in the panini
again the complexity how much  e
preliminary work,
both in terms of materials but
also of know-how, is necessary in order
to be able to manufacture these products with technology. a typical example is
the topic of rare earths, where we
implement
high-tech products for many products,
be it for batteries or for mobile phones  rare he
necessary 70 percent of the rare earths
are either in china or
are under the control of china, which of
course in turn is a bit of a
challenge when it comes to
sovereignty sovereignty i.e. self-determination
independence from individual players
but there we are increasingly dependent on
global supply chains that will be
will continue to increase in the future and
intensify again the third
reason has something to do with the demand
so if you ask technologies are
not developed out of a vacuum
but with a certain goal of a
certain to satisfy a certain demand
and that also arises  for
many and  the question of who buys
this technology, who needs it
and the issue of scalability is also
important there where we realize the national
market is in most cases far too
small, especially if you think from a
german perspective but here
also a european need a
global
need or the  consider global demand here
the fourth reason
for me on the subject of sovereignty
has something to do with standards
which standards do we want to create in order
to control technology development implementation implementation
then it’s about ethical standards you think about it
in medical technology that
prions were developed in china where
we in germany
we couldn't even
imagine it's about things like data protection
personal protection it's about the
topic of
consumer protection and also the
question of iso i.e. industrial
standards and that is a very, very
essential dimension if you
how you develop technologies and
then implement and use them and that’s
why for me the topic of sovereignty
is a very strong global component
where we have to think globally and take
these four dimensions into account
at the same time it’s not just something where
you say we have local or national ones
Sovereignty has been lost in
a certain way over the decades and it can also
be seen the other way around and say we have increasingly gained in design possibilities, we have to
develop technologies further about it
, but for that we have to think
sovereignty really globally, the
networks think with us, the
interdependencies also think
along with us now in the pandemic on the topic  supply chains are
considering how we can create resilience and resistance in
order to meet the
challenge and more than
a last point
interaction networks means of course
that you have many different strong
partners and especially the local
ones the interaction between  en people are
important and I see a huge
opportunity for berlin in many areas
clearly
materials science of the past
medical technology on lists of other
areas in many of these areas
berlin plays an important role in the
future can still play an important role thank you very
much Mr. researcher for  your
contribution at this point, which obviously
offers starting points for discussion
and i invite you from the podium to
ask questions will listen to
fratzscher would like to move forward
then i would perhaps start briefly
you had aligned it globally but
i would also provocatively
counter you at this point we
get ready to live on a planet
with ten billion people
we get ready to live on a planet
where
national interests
we unfortunately have to observe have become stronger
in international trade and
live on a planet where
system and values conflicts also occur  In
your opinion, it will always be possible to resolve
what we all wish for
such conflicts in a win-win
situation, or will there
also clearly be a situation that
creates winners and losers and
I understand the discussion about technology
sovereignty that is now increasingly coming into
focus  device science research
development technology to look at from the
perspective of technology development
to get strong there
don't want to be sure i have confessed the question of
course there are strong
national interests but it's nothing
new i think it was always like that
and we realize take the topic
drexhage that going it alone nationally will
not lead to more sovereignty
and so fewer sovereignties
sovereignty can only be understood as shared
sovereignty,
especially in research and
development the complexities in which
one cannot say that
we do it in one place  and can really be
locally sovereign there and now with regard to the
conflicts there are winners or
losers we have seen for some
time now broadly speaking
not in the technology sector in other
areas of
sovereignty that globalization has
many losers and we are talking about
economics  from hyper hyper
globalization that is in some
areas globalization is going too
far that leads to massive
job losses, for example
, so what has the real consequences for people
certainly also
plays a role behind the social
polarization that we
have seen in the usa, for example
dragset can also be interpreted in this light in other western countries too,
so the short answer is no, there are
not only winners but also
losers because there aren't and what worries me
now from an ecological and social
perspective is the
speed of change, which is
increasing  has and that is
a chance for many people another example in the
material development of nine months was
a past is 10 15 lasted 20 years
has is a huge chance
but for many people it is also
a threat so we have
to think about this social component as well  because
technological sovereignty also
requires a degree of social acceptance
that people say yes, we accept
these global interdependencies and also
raise the risks associated with them
ok thank you very much a contribution there are
still suggestions
there is a
queue accept them for a moment yes if i may
i would  like a question then
sovereignty different
dimensions explained
disabled this also raises a need for
action for you in one of this
definition and where would you
see this need for action if necessary
for me here is a very specific
need for action my steps as addressed we see we are
increasingly in a global
system competition politically
economically between usa china and
for us in europe the question must be
do we want to have a voice in this system competition
should it then be a
bipolar polar world order that
europe can also bring its values its conception its i
eas and we fr
m a german  perspective
you are just a small economy
a small country with a limited amount of
influence and for me the specific need for
action is we need a city
need stronger integration at the
european level in
terms of economic policy i would also be traveling with research development earlier if the trendy now the
successor  programs there, too, wish
that we initiate more European projects,
because only if Europe speaks more
with one voice can we
really also protect our sovereignty, that is to
say the ideal, the values, ethical
data protection, consumer protection and other
things and ultimately also
economically  I and that's why my first recommendation would be
that we need European integration
if I may add a
second element for a moment I
think the differences in the
political systems and also a
value system China is an extreme
example
with completely different standards in
technological development
too  i would wish for a much
closer cooperation between the usa and
europe, but we will also share more values in this area and a
ain for me, t
is fourth point is the question of who s
ts the standards of the future the decis
ve question which technologies will
revail and which
standards  this technology
development also really deserves a lot of
thanks then Frau Kunst will still
invite you if you now take the
connection between global and regional
again into the center
of your considerations then the question is actually
which strengths are given the difficulty of also acting on a
European basis
got to  you have to work out here in particular
to actually also as europe with the
global competitive disadvantage you
just said that in china it is
actually such a different world of
standards and opportunities to
take action to
partly
prescribe technology development
so how do you make up for the disadvantage
that we are attached to other ethical concepts
bind ourselves and couple that with an
emphasis on the strength of the elements that
we can also do here, so in the past it was
said that the german engineer could
reconnect with his practice, so i
know that was at the time at the time of
training because of
certain
peculiarities  so also prove themselves
in the global market and how would you have to
layer that again today with a completely different structure in order to
actually make the regional
strength effective for europe
if i 2 2 parts of the answer one
defensive and one offensive the
defensive answer  is exactly what I
just said  gt, with
close cooperation with
the usa, has to say to the chinese
that it should really set global standards if you
want to sell certain products in europe, i.e. those that are
manufactured using technology, then
they must also
comply with certain standards that is a defensive
argument the offensive argument is in favor
me what makes europe special what makes
europe strong that for me is definitely
the diversity and maybe it is quite
far away from the
natural sciences the
social contract the
way we live together as a
society and the question of how
successful one is depends yes
always thinking above all about the people, about
whether you can hand down the brightest minds
and give them the
freedom to develop and
implement ideas
and i see a great chance that
we can offer this freedom and also the framework
for it i think there  are
the usa and in some ahead if
you now be very clumsy clumsy
iplay but the question of who wins the
nobel prizes in the natural sciences
, they are usually not necessarily
americans but scientists
who work in the usa i think
we should look in europe to see how we can make it
better to get the brightest minds to
europe thank you very much mrs kunz
thank you very much then i would go ahead and invite you to a second impulse mr. beier the bmbf has presented exciting papers important
papers technological
sovereignty materials research we are
excited
thank you very much for the opportunity to present
some points then in fact the term
technical
sovereignty is also at  to be sorry
has become a concept in the last 1 2 1 2
years that has a lot to do with what
we already highlighted from different perspectives in the first round of discussions
on sovereignty
has the technical data technological
aspects
one noticed that there were
critical technological elements british  e
technologies gives you a whole
lot of areas from the market major
scientific competition works
if you don't master them,
but you have also found that
the one big task is to ensure that you
have a narrow concept of what is supposed to be reality
behind from the area of research that
ou  on a dynamic
key field is on an equal
footing is certainly the
discussion g the new
communication network was an eye-opener for me
when it was found that the european
and also the american ones
cannot keep up with the chinese offers,
be it the technicians but above
all from an economic point of view
but also from a technological point of
view that was the frightening thing we see the discussion about the
so-called bypass skaters, i.e. the
short databases, the cloud systems
which are dominated by the chinese and americans
and the danger that
a large part of intellectual property will end up in
this albers trowel
r is the trend of the time people
are going to the cloud to
store and process their data and
if this large space can no longer be
influenced in Europe
then there was the great concern that
we would also lose part of our
our influence  and also our possibilities for
further development
these were a few different sources
from which the discussion and
technological reality we are
aware that you can look at it very differently
and in a differentiated way there
is next to the technological as soon as it is
also the economic reality the
prospectus is explained if you do it
yourself  something that is technically possible is also
a good chance to buy only now
if the sources of supply are
not secured so you don't come under pressure pressure under
value the point of view when
you buy these things we in the
research ministry look at
technological sanity we do
n't understand quality like that as well  en  r the dakar rally
but we understand sovereignty as
being involved in important key areas
and shaping them insofar we have been very clever with
our agenda in recent years
we are keeping an eye on the
technologies in my department after
the next generation
it's about the quanta, quantum
computing, it's about the successor to the network,
what's being rolled out on it, more like and
six, it's about
microelectronics, we all have it
regularly in the news,
and last but not least, it's just
about that  the topic of material itself is
responsible for e.g. the whole topic of
battery development we have seen
that
this dynamic development was also very
strongly dominated from abroad
we believe we have
caught up a lot here in recent years
so focus on the
technological skills of the
next generation and the one after that  here
again at eye level stä  rker on
full area coverage he on
eyes to be there and to play along
exactly in these international
networks that have already been mentioned
if you interrupt the last
thought on that already in the field
of material
development scientifically then
this also means that here and a
large part always below  the
experts come from this field but that we
have a key field here which we have to
develop we have also
initiated a strategy process here a federal paper has been given
the discussion where
do we want to play here as germany where do we
see our strengths
what do we see as  the central trends
that we have to serve before the big wave
this includes, for example
, the digitization of
material research, i.e. material digital,
almost everything we have to do with
digital today in the
future must be made stronger
that is a very, very large area that needs to be
dealt with  there are big initiatives in
this field we see learning
from nature as the next big wave
that will bring many surprises the topic of
learning organic principles from bio
intelligence and of course we see
fields like the battery material
presentation in the battery the next
big steps there  win a solid
-state battery with great potential,
which we absolutely want to be at the forefront
of, so
we are very happy that this
research facility has
now been found
by leighton too
that you come
to these points in a great
strategic dialogue
thank you very much then open and offer the
round of surveys at this point there are
contributions from the
audience again afterwards
but yes then I would
start briefly at this point so I understand
the bmbf papers in this way  that
technological sovereign  ity is of course
not thought of nationally, it is thought
very strongly in European terms
and of course no self-sufficient path is
defined, but it shouldn’t be
dependent either, but an autonomous path
that means we want to be able to
determine if I keep pressing down
on them  materials research would be
and the following was also mentioned there is
an extreme acceleration worldwide in the
innovation process what are the
measures what are the tools that you see
in
the focus of the bmbf and with this
accelerated history of innovation
also at the level of
materials research to keep up in
germany europe
so we have  we have a very broad and
rich
research landscape you have to
see that you are in the guiding principles
that is fraunhofer that is the reynolds
institute and nothing flex the
universities the initiatives of the bmbf
and therefore rely on it
analyze if things are
going well in some fields  i.e  he
discussion and setting new
priorities against the background,
all of the following comments should always be made
, so if the bmw
doesn’t do anything for more whining, a field can
develop really well,
but in the two material we are using
exactly these priorities we have been using for
years  program there on the way we
focus from our point of view on
central key development and
want this to
be strengthened as well
that is, these models and these digital ones can
also interact with each other,
so here is a clear network approach, we
see the value principles as a big
money  more than in the past on
the topic of sustainability
the material is at the beginning of the
value chain
insofar as material questions but you ask
the questions
in which direction cycles can be
closed it remains very
bitter we will do big initiatives
there on the narrow and of
course the big strategic
falls  battery that which which will be a
central industrial policy question of the
proposals years with
highly dynamic developments nothing
today is the same as it was two years ago
and in two years with the world on
it you can see the appearance of everything
connected with networks and
communication platforms in this
community well  then
Mrs. Kunst Mr. Beyer you are today bmbf
allow me to ask you a question
when talking about technological
sovereignty to what extent he is
the bmbf active as a
key ministry also the
further steps then actually for
production in the direction of economy
from your program line  n
to be able
to make good mistakes so on the one hand we don't have any
coalition negotiations and of course
I only say that the primacy of
politics and they have
invited someone here today who comes from the middle of the
administration insofar as what I say
is basically the point of view  the
ministry and another
body will discuss and decide whether the guidelines for the
coming years will of
course we have
always had a strong focus and
would continue
to suggest this is that
in the area of implementing the value
chain completely we al
o  so go further
basic research warned that such a
battery mentioned that we even go so
far as to
build the research object and learn processes
technology on the spot is very
crucial that then the interface
to the colleagues in the Ministry of
Economics who then also have to present the
connection and
industrial policy and it's a lot
cut  written
here hand in hand and the
handover will be very decisive for the coming years
if you
want to be successful positive examples
then there are also negative examples you
all know that people think a lot
in this area but there are many
positive examples  on which one could build
thank you very much sir almost only
reported briefly as the last question then
closes what would have said for us i
a perspective of
economics
we often realize that
there is a problem with the implementation of
scalability that products technology
products are then really marketable
and of course that includes the
interaction between science
and practice, i.e. the economy, but also
coming
back specifically to berlin.
berlin has a huge strength in the
area of
up companies. young companies that take up id
as, they try to devel
p them, but then it happe
s  very common that if di  ese products
these ideas will be marketable will you
go abroad to emigrate to the usa
and that often includes the issue of
financing but that after 34
years of risk
capital to really ensure this scalability and
then again it’s less of a
question more  one comment to say
here too the
european dimension is important again because we ultimately need a
capital market we need
more risk capital again the
connection between science and
technology development and business and financial
markets to underline that again great thank you very
much then we would start the
first block with that  decide and
come to our second topic,
which revolves around strategies for the formation of
innovation networks, yes, we have
heard accelerated innovation
cycles, highly cooperative units are needed, i think these are all steep templates for women from the
fraunhofer-
gesellschaft according to the statutes  and also from the
self-image initially
competent based reduced but
dennis announce that means
we are joining institutes to form a
network as we work in similar
fields of competence so in
our sense that
materials science and
materials technology that happens of course
quite healthy sporting
scientific competition but also
in addition to each other of course  that's how it was
in our tree and so that of
course the individual institutes, there
are 16 in number, have their respective
focus either on
a specific material or on a
specific technology, but there is
also this very consciously
healthy sporting scientific
competition and if you  now coming to the topic of
innovation it is a natural
part of tradition that institutes use
their skills to initiate
colorful innovations in their customers'
markets generations to
shadow and in this respect i  m
interaction with several partners from
the evaluation but it is also possible that
there emphasize with your partners in the
university environment and
colleagues from the other
non-university
research institutions an
innovation network or are about a
corresponding usual why our
network are innovation
networks and this aspect yes
it is, so to speak
the negligence that the
entire city bus should have been part of it, starting
with university research right
up to application-oriented research
that is of course a very
important aspect for us and to come back to the
technological topic and the
context of the metal innovation days is
also one of our work is  Among
other things, the paper was created, but
you also referred to it directly a few
times and it is clearly
shown that the
necessary prerequisite for technological solidity is
an innovation to be managed and that
in turn is also no  Necessary front building
thereby sufficient Both are
sufficient but necessary for the
economic sovereignty the father
addressed and now of
course it will not be surprising that the
view is also true
components used say the core of
technological sovereignty but are
really or is a city of
materials science and
materials technology in  germany
or europe so
maybe for a start there is of
course a lot of evidence why that
is the case, why we think that we simply have
very, very good chances of achieving
technological sovereignty, for
example in the area of the energy trans
tion  now there has been strong cooperation
universities non-university students
might as well get the
opinion of
the helmholtz society and
ask mr kraft because they can offer a
successful integration space from the
university d  a we are
curious to
hear how you are also
thanks good morning to the vice president
for research at the karlsruher institute for
technology and we call
ourselves the
research university in the helmholtz
community and that alone shows
that we have a unique position
we have, so to speak, the interface between
non-university and university
research in house we are both
a state university and a
helmholtz center and a member of the
helmholtz association
i don’t want
to talk so much about how
we always sort it out that’s a story
in itself  and has perhaps also led to
some frictional losses
in recent years, but
apart from that,
i think the cooperation
between the non-university
research institutions and universities
is extremely important and would also like to use
an example that is
not now internal to karlsruhe  Change
our
long-term cooperation with the
University of Ulm in the field of
battery research,
material development for the batteries
there and I
believe that for
technological sovereignty and
interdisciplinary cooperation it is
important that we have a wide range of
disciplines and that is
ultimately one  strength of the german
university system that we have
that you can't talk about it
we weren't better overall in the rankings
so do it but i'm
still firmly convinced
that we offer very good
academic training
and young
researchers and the breadth
is also a basis if you
also hold on to your own strengths and
now you can ask the question why
are we working with him on the battery issue in particular
the university of ulm has
changed in the 1990s in contrast
to most of the others
German universities decided
not to abolish their electrochemistry chairs
, but to retain them,
even to expand the topic
and to strengthen it, and when
the topic of batteries suddenly became important in the late 2,000 years
,
the tesla shock this time, so all of
a sudden there was a company in  usa that claims
they can build fully electric cars
and that of course caused a certain uproar in the german
automotive industry, at least temporarily
, after that wall
calmed down a bit i had the impression
and then it took a few years
to realize that he had to do something
and in  at that time we then
decided
to found the helmholtz institute in ulm as a
helmholtz center in this cooperation with the
university and meanwhile the
institute is the
cooperation with
the aga national lab and tennis academy
of science institutes among the  top 3
what the worldwide batteryfo  research
is concerned
and together clusters of excellence too and
immediately so what now shows that in
my opinion we
really need a discipline its breadth to be
prepared for different
developments you can’t
believe that research
will deliver the return on investment tomorrow
, so to speak, but about that  is ultimately
much more long-term and thinks very much together
with competence and competence development
and then the
non-university institutions have the
chance to support specific topics with
more staying power and also larger budgets
in order to raise such a topic
accordingly
and you have just
heard from the bmbf battery  a
key issue is solving a lot of important details
on the material side just
do i get non-violent batteries how
do i get batteries that are manufactured from the start in a
way that you can give them a
circular economy so
recovering materials solid state
electrolyte you will see  n whether that will be the
next major step
up to lithium-free batteries for
stationary applications in ten years,
once we have rebuilt the energy
system, so many many open
questions and i think ultimately,
as i said, you need the complete, i.e. the
concentrated competence  to achieve
and that perhaps as the last word that
we now play along on the subject
cell production in
germany is not only
funded in research factories but
also by the industry itself is
possible because for ten
fifteen years now we have been
trained accordingly in the in  the specialist areas are great
thank you very much then I invite you to
the point for discussion who would have
questions comments on the two speakers
woman
you don't if someone from the
women take over exactly before when you
want you take over briefly yes very
briefly he otherwise wanted a
bridge  on two years was hit because
yes too  the topic of
internationality again to talk about how
important it is
to be able to tackle and solve social problems holistically and because
politics question the formats that
are required for this and you have
now defined and constructed this
matter in the bmbf relatively young
and  I do
n't think that's exactly the idea
of what can be worked together in a business-oriented manner from a wide
ariety of disciplines but also
rom a wide variety of organ
zational forms
That
asn't possible before in this breadth and s
I'm looking forward to it  i th
that can make a big contribution thank you very much mrs.
there are more
requests to speak on the topic of women's
art so you
might ask a question directly
oliver kraft but also to women because
we're talking about the topic of batteries is
also a very exciting topic  if
on the one hand you can see how you build up
research capacity and
training capacity again how much
movement there you have but
at the same time that is now also for here
say
berlin-brandenburg environment we also have
a small tesla shock
maybe a positive one so
we have tesla on site now with battery production
with basf they i think are very
important when thinking about material chains they
were always very early in the
material chains also for
batteries maybe oliver you
could comment again how the
national strategy in this whole
environment is seen there from the research point of
view  you might want to add a
heretical question,
sir, you
just said that you are the
research university in the
helmholtz association
here in berlin, we are taking a
different approach, that we are trying to
develop and raise our profile at the
university, that is, one  common
to find a definition in which direction
we want to go together and see
a special opportunity in it not only to work
together with light wood but also
with many
ask karlsruhe that too or are
you slavishly tied to light wood
we are not tied to light wood
i think and i think so  the constellation in
karlsruhe was special so it could
not be copied the fact
that we have our clusters with the
universiade berg another class
with the uni ulm
a european university
affiliated new choir have been there for many
years it shows that we are
not only now in  cook our own juice
but work closely with other universities there
will be a whole
series of colleagues from fraunhofer there
is also one colleague yes and colleagues who
have their professors with us what
we are missing a bit in karlsruhe is
max planck so we would take them
immediately if they  max planck
society  then decides to
settle an institute with us as we are
not enough for ourselves in that sense but
really trade it as a platform what
i think what karlsruhe
has actually
shown is that the permeability simply has to become
greater between
university and non-university
research, no matter which one
the facilities are there
so i think that's when you
say that's what you were able to
learn and ultimately the
change from 91 b i think has
something to do with the fact that you simply
saw something had to be done
with it  so to speak, since the
federal government
can also do and promote more at the state level,
that's one part of the other part
again to the recyclable material,
so I
think that in the future you
shouldn't really separate between material and
an application, but instead
ultimately we have to think in terms of material systems
and that has a lot to do
with kre  is running economy together
so how much if we have to put several together with the
material and how it is
processed, so to speak, how I can take the
product apart again behind
all the way back to the material or
to the individual components to
suddenly come to a
cycle because they have  guess now
sfb initiative there the word comes before
the eternal product so in the sense of
mine, so to speak, at the atomic level
everything is eternal
but ultimately also in
terms of materials components so
and i think that's an important point
and that's why i wouldn't do it that way
separate because that's really
from synthetic chemistry to
the machine builder at the very other end
who builds the machine for it
because everything is ultimately
connected and that's yes and
that's of course also in the training
with a big challenge,
so to speak  to sensitize engineers to this
and vice versa the
materials science  he doesn't just
say yes in the laboratory but
ultimately must also
be able to get an exciting perspective in the product then
i would hand over at this point imminent
right the times from
frankfurt he is innocent then you
have another question but let's continue
like the term just built
what was needed from the permeability was that it had to be greater i find that to be very
not only clever but also only a few
assessments and the question is here
in germany they are actually
quite good but do we have to become even more
pervious in our
structures and formats and
format templates
that  would be a question that i
would like to see addressed to my colleagues in
bavaria but rather to the representatives on
the podium what what they themselves say
scientifically
do here we have to become more
permeable or are we already permeable
enough in germany with our i
can't think of a way around  successful and
also
innovation system  of research and
research funding
that's what I would
say okay then I'd say
answering the question from Ms. Carola who would like to do
Ms. Kunst
so Ms. Koch under very we have
very many very many common
appointments with if you relate it to
humboldt next to
440  professorships almost almost 80 s
professorships that are also appointed jointly with the
non-university
research institutions in
order to further develop what you just mentioned,
essential regulation was also required in the state of
berlin in order to actually improve the
permeability in the interests of both sides, i.e.
a
change also unite at the points
where  the colleagues from the
non-university institutions at the
university want to do something but it doesn't work in
many places they know the
problem because in berlin it is still
not regulated that capacity is not
mentioned for the
university and that is a great feat in the kit
that you  that has succeeded in gre
nzen in the district
knows that baden-wuerttemberg also works magic there
, but i think it's actually about
promoting permeability and synergies in the
sense of those who really work
there, there's a lot of
craftsmanship that
would unlock a lot again right now  when you see
a location like adlershof
,
we've been discussing it for a long time, but
it really is a cardinal
problem that needs to be solved so that the
young people who are now coming from the
non-university
research institutes also have a wide range of
development opportunities from
industry to university and the path for
them too  it remains open
to do one like the other and vice versa,
so we also have to do our
homework,
but that's why we crack the craft
exactly at this point and i think it's
great that we succeeded in karlsruhe
if you stood here and there
maybe  very short comment but
then we have to continue for reasons of time
me a little
i've been
negotiating the law on further education for two years now and
just an addition to
what's possible is that
between the part and the
research center style investigation
people are sometimes
pushed back and forth in terms of capacity that's the
great
attraction then
we are all very curious about this model and how
it has performed over the past few years,
i think it's something
new, you're right, mr. beyer,
that's really a great approach and
that might be something
to try in berlin
then i would hand it over to bernd rösch to
take a closer look at the cooperation from the university at the adlershof location
thank you very much thank you very much for
introducing myself briefly while
legal and scientific managing director helmut zentrum berlin there responsible for energy and information and professor at the technical university berlin berbens gratis  learned too  and i we
are very close together oliver kraft
and i it is a very
successful model for many things we have also learned
we can also learn some of it in berlin
but of course there are the
special features that we have in berlin and i will
come straight to the campus
adlershof come where we also have our
great strengths and
outstanding that with the berlin
university alliance has its country or
region second
internationally visible excellent
network or an alliance has
emerged we have now also
merged the more than 50
non-university research institutes in berlin
to also work together  to advance things together with this great
alliance and with the
senate administration i
think there was an unbelievably
large potential you can also tell by
the growth in the city
the high start-up culture was mentioned
but also the settlement of
large new companies in berlin-brandenburg
we have to  yes this ra  in any case, to
think very strongly together when we
think about the metropolitan region when
we come to the topic of materials on the
topic of material and theology
sovereignty i believe the location
campus adlershof is
outstandingly placed there in the possibilities
the entire value chain is formed there
whether it is a
science and business location
humboldt university is there with its
scientifically oriented
institutes of computer science a
whole new research paul has been
created a new institute for
materials
materials science
will be created but they are already there and
i think this is where it
shows that we  Today
, not only the
non-university adlershof with the
humboldt university work very closely together, but also our
non-university ones in the others who
are connected to the other
universities in Berlin and Brandenburg,
so I think this is the
univer here  sity a nucleus we are there
in many small working levels
exactly what woman art addressed
really this permeability to live
in the common vocations it will
help us a lot if the
things
are still simple we have but at the same time on site so
we have the helmholtz center berlin
a synchrotron besse 2 for
materials research we have top
international
metrology for metrology, the physico-technical
federal institute, the federal
office for materials testing, and of
course the institutes in the
research association berlin, which are very
well equipped in terms of materials research like grandma used to be
, that is a
very, very strong one  potential that
we can and must increase more if we
look at the future material
issues i think the adlershof campus has a particularly strong
need there for materials of the next
generation is moving from 2d materials
for example but also gallium oxide for
the semiconductor  industry for photonics
we have a very strong focus
on new materials
for energy for von barofsky-based
photovoltaic materials new aspects
with the max planck society for
thin-film catalysts which we are
therefore strengthening a very very large
material-scientific focus
with a unique analysis and with
a single  finished linking in the
higher education sector and that and in order
to further strengthen that now i think and
that is a big question when it comes to material
and technology sovereignty is where
do we have the thematic priorities
that we have now set how can
we further develop them in a national
context in national cooperation
and  but then with the real obligation
to European and thus also
international leadership at which points
can we
further strengthen these interfaces and that is the
interface between the university
and the research institutes
, but that's what we discussed  especially
to the industry in the area of startups and a
so
he newly settled large compa
ies, which I think are extremely important for the succe
s of the energy transition and material trans
tion and one last
oint that I might
want to say at this point, it also came
rom  different places when we
step on new materials new technologies the point naturally comes how
do we manage to bring that into the indie production
and into the products and there
is the point that is
mentioned here it then becomes very expensive one
still talks about the wave it
often  with some technologies they manage
to get through this very critical
phase and i think we need
joint real drilling with the
institutes uses with industry but
above all usable between
universities non-university
research in very simple and clear
cooperation possibilities than we
need  we need it there too  s
right
rules and then i think
we can take a big
step forward
many thanks band are there comments suggestions
would only then take up the comment
we have the problem in berlin
that we don't often don't have the big
players  the industrial landscape here on
site with its production and
research location has a very
colorful start-up culture i think that
we are extremely exciting whether in the
preparation of next generation
technologies as it was also
mentioned that we are closely
networking there with the start-up  culture and
then i also find it very exciting
with economics know from my
own experience it is actually
relatively easy to found a start-up
but if you then have
to scale from ten people to 50 people that
is exactly the point where the money
comes from somewhere else and  our
potential technologies are
sold and, among other things, g
then i would go to the third block
and strengthen partnerships
frauke unter der
decke berlin has run extremely ambitious the program in recent years to
expand the city of science to expand the city of
knowledge
the mayor has made it a top
priority and i know from close
interaction with your house that
you and your colleagues
are extremely committed
thank you very much for being here today and
I look forward to your contribution
yes i was
very interested in the discussions i also contributed
a bit
and now he has put my actual
statement aside because
certain aspects that i
wanted to take up again here have already emerged in
the discussion that need
not be repeated i believe that we are
already
making good progress in germany in terms of technological
sovereignty overall and there are also
certain limits, so to speak
stepping common thinking after building space
grabbed there i work for good and
necessary because understanding key technologies
but also developing and
producing are absolutely not
much less than securing our
prosperity our jobs
but they also find city in a system
of democratic common
ground and  I'd like to
say that here he writes differently here in the round also mentioned again
really quickly further developing
technologies are changing our
societies rapidly and are doing so
in a way the big concern he guesses
I'll just say the key word
influencing bathrooms  bellenberger
voices in democracies that
would be possible through technology that we had 15
years ago will be available to me in
this respect there are
also completely
new challenges with which,
in particular, those in western lic
Societies clearly miss the model and the
shift, yes, but we have a
model that radiates worldwide so
there is also cause for considerable
concern about ensuring sales
from democracies on land, but there are
also gigantic opportunities
and the technology is
sovereignty policy  one that has
sometimes made incorrect
statements that have
to be driven and tied back in global and international thinking i
think that is fundamentally contradicted it
is well expressed at the national level that is the
second level next to the
global one in which the two
responsible departments first
federal research ministry  but
the Federal Ministry of Economics
is also increasingly pursuing the trend to develop clever focal points fields of
application similarly caused it
I believe
to develop healthy competitive constellations
decided together so there are quite a
few strategies against which
w  earth but you then decide at
the top of the ministries of the
federal ministries for certain
priorities you don’t do that in a
vacuum but rather to
incorporate and discourse that’s an
exceptionally good thing there and i think
the path
we’re taking in
berlin is already bearing many many fruits  so to speak, also in a post
pull move in front of a science and
research policy in recent years
also sustainably for enormously deeply lead
and bring further it has already been
mentioned that guilt has said it wife
and I that we have a one,
you could almost say, roar of
development  in science,
in recent years,
the political leadership of our
city in various places has been
intensified,
stimulated by voices from
science,
made possible by the
leadership expanded  ren
fields to try these new chances, so to speak,
the new clusters, the new
development
i think it is right that we say little in
a button down and and in a
political way,
so to speak, daughter of a
politically enabled way in this
interaction game, your share is ahead of
us  it is still important that the
non-university
research institutions
do their work so successfully here in
berlin, that they
naturally develop clever ideas in their own context in their
respective contexts and
that they work
with their heads on their own. for this you need the
right minds at
the top  looking for synergies
focus looking looking ahead
want to do this together
we are dependent on people working in
the facility and i
believe that we have
made little progress here in recent years
the fact that thomas schröder this
strategy leadership in de  r founded the leibniz
community after
making sure that the
leibniz community can still
benefit from this idea, so to speak,
thomas schröder and his colleagues continue to
bring this research organization in
for
the fraunhofer self-image the key word
competence networks innovation alliances
has already been mentioned we have in
berlin also some
and i believe this strong development
out of itself with intelligent and think outside the
box thinking
the scientific minds also
enables successful work i already
form and i find it absolutely
desirable and in
need of further development both the university side
in berlin in the format of  citizens has come
together and that the
non-university students who are in their
different fields but also with
their colleagues in closer cooperation
that is clever and that is
perhaps also exemplary in berlin
on the way to  on the subject of material
sovereignty bernd is right believes the
landscape is essentially a chance briefly
outline that i want to repeat that now
we share that of course
you should also mention the dlr ferdinand brown
institute of course our
fraunhofer institutes we are
on the move here on a broad front and
want to conclude  let me just say
something co is an example of the fact
that the path towards production,
at least in small series, is also developing
as the hof also had its strength in the
fact that
production is at least on a smaller
scale around
research institutions and, so to speak,
also
goes into production in this vicinity  and we believe that we have laid out
these lines in such a way that with
the active people looking across
the valleys some of them 17 also have the
best possible chance here a bit
also exemplary berlin has to be a
bit careful there are
other places in germany i do
n't want to  say envy a  But watch very
closely what is not planned in
berlin we should take that as a
compliment and be smart and cooperative and
coordinated far i look forward to it
and try to help where we can see a
lot of tact for the women's choir
then i would ask podium
speeches  do you have any comments from mrs.
art maybe i can
tie in with mr. rech a bit in the sense of concretizing the statements made by ms.
koch under “contribute a
lot” in adlershof we actually have
the special situation that
science on the part of the university with the
non-university and
commercial companies are all in one place
and at the same time you can see that
there must be new ways to
continue to be successful there for the
future. this includes the fact that the mutual approach
between
non-university and universities
has led to the
university making the fundamental
decision about the faculty and the
faculty for  mom
to profile the topic and natural sciences in the
sense of a future topic,
for example, around the
materials sciences and for this
as a crystallization
cent uses the research building iris adlershof
and if you see what is
happening there and what has happened
recently, it is that the just
opened catalysis center cutler
shows how broadly the possibilities
of the non-university
research institutions are active there
with both the work on the part of the max planck
society and helmholtz and
so that we have a very special
constellation
there and
that new results can be expected in
the near future in the research field of catalysis
or rather, hydrogen generation,
i think that's kind of great
that it was successful and that it was actually possible
from the bottom up because of the good
cooperation in adlershof or to give you
another example if you allow
two more minutes to make
the decision now  to position yourself particularly well in the field of
materials science
if you
really want to make it fruitful means
that the structures of the
university,
to speak of my achievements, should adapt to the ideal
, on the one hand, in the
direction of a future of
excellent natural sciences  but also
with a view to application and next
steps
to go so far that the
intermediate pieces are easier because in
addition to the good and excellent start-up
scene in adlershof, there is
actually a problem with where in berlin or where in the
research area you can actually take the
next steps and also  With
combatants, who
will then continue to come to Adlershof due to the excellent training and
the start-up scene in
order to lay the preparation for
technological sovereignty there and
our intention is actually to lay the basis for
technological sovereignty and
that in an
interdisciplinary way  top
-level scientific research oriented towards application
and we are really good at that. the
alliance is an important
vehicle in this respect
because the forms of cooperation that
are possible in the alliance make it possible for project
connections to be temporary members of all
berlin universities that
is the real hit now  the
interface between
non-university and university
cooperation if you
have solved it differently but here the
basis has been laid that you are a member of the eu
as well as the hna
from adlershof
to dahlem
and can actually move in a
permeable research area there
i have now
formulated the ideal everyone who is sitting here knows
that sometimes one way or
another in berlin is rocky so that
now mrs. koch unterseer year
your support to roll away the stones
in many thanks for
such a beautiful film for art and then
i would  one  n invite you to speeches from the
podium but i
think we are now ready to welcome questions from the
audience or woman
has answered
under the
permeability we have concentrated very much
on the permeability
between
universities and the non-university
research institutions and there
i think that you can say really well and
rightly what was
so much lamented ten 15 years ago in the german
research landscape this supply
i think it has largely
broken up but where we
should now
adlershof make an exception and this without a
back door summer ball where  we
and germany could possibly improve
that is also the permeability
between the different
non-university
research organizations
there was once in the program
build up hofer marx then forward ahlen
which also supports financial decisions by the respective board members
was and was
also motivated but
all in all it's not that
easy in our years it's first
legally so I think there's still
potential for expansion at this point and then
on the subject of course that also
has something to do with permeability in the
directions of
basic research other than  to the
right application line innovation
whatever it is the market on the other hand there
is of course also a big challenge
very early on to get
the industrial or
business-related users on board, especially for
medium-sized companies and
I think you can do something in the
direction of through the universe  these are
sometimes different worlds
is nice leading then woman and
other questions
i would like to start with women and
added i think that is a very, very important point that i think is a very,
very important point
that i just said for
materials research materials science
when we talk about acceleration when
we  talk about new ones realizing  For some, knowledge will still
lead to a product much more quickly
if you give it to the outside world. The classic way.
I have a basic research max
plan, maybe at the universities. I have
Frauenhofer who make a transfer
for certain tasks
there has been a very, very big
change already in the
description of what basic
research is what is applied research, also at eu
level the concept of frontiers research
i think that is a very important
point that we probably
cannot go into any further here, but i
hope  at least that we will also do it within the
framework of our bf 50 with the berlin
university alone because all
these scientific institutions there and the
various
selection deficits are now trying together to think that we can take a step forward hopefully one that will be very very successful and there as a role model
serves and then the uni  strength comes
and says we did it
ok that's nice we still have a
word from the audience
what do we get a microphone let's have a
look at me can't you hear alright
yes I introduce myself shortly before my
name is robert maas I suffer the
department for  materials science and
materials technology
so i have a question or 1 comment
about a point that hasn't got
through so well then i
would like to have explained a bit about the panel
then i
might have a thematic
focus suggestion in the direction of
bavaria's bmbf
first of all many thanks
very stimulating for the interesting discussion
we talked for a long time about technology and
ried material sovereignty
innovation and that's what's going through my
head, yes, because generally all
developments that I have such a material
scientific research series that
also come in new products
are increasingly  Let's say complex from the point of
view of materials science and
initially we also talked about the
fact that we have
dependencies in the direction of various
elements, that can be done
by the gentleman who has the
economic research institute, yes,
and then it also
came through to Mr Kraft about the batteries with the
kobold,
these are geopolitical dependencies
that we are dealing with here
undergo and the question for me is
so that was articulated a bit less
in the discussion i
don't know how you see
it i would like to hear your opinion because of
course if we want to develop new technologies we only have
to take that into
account  is, so to speak,
just like biologization or
digitalization in
materials science and that we are
increasingly becoming a sensitive issue because we are
generally becoming more and more complicated in all materials systems,
so it was a suggestion, so to speak, of
a question from and in the direction of
Mr. Bavaria
's bmbf  main emphasis  which one could
perhaps look at again, the
strategy paper that we discussed at the beginning of
the year, that we
then tap into these things in the direction of institutional
materials science, which would go in the direction of reducing
dependencies
or perhaps also address sustainability
right at the beginning of the
value
chain, that was all for many
thanks then but would like to reply
to that at the point
on the meaning of situations
substitution material research i
wanted to go over briefly a Bavarian then requires
other strength
so this area had to
be sharpened
and focused in the
strategy paper what is important to you we have this topic that the of  composite materials
on the one hand and the
challenges of the design of
materials as the first stage of an
economy on the circular economy
material efficiency circle the
capability these are the major issues the
si  cherlich very much in the foreground
that gives me the
opportunity
to do a central point again because if
you do that then the topic of high
scaling is
a very important one it's not
just about the cooperation in the most
diverse areas but
the high scaling of innovative
developments that are great for us the floors
are completely new from talks
as the central approach just
described i'm going we're also
investigating the also over the
existing venture
capital joint projects you're also
trying to find new
starting points for every suggestion  every
lecture because highly grateful if the
material research in any case in the
coming months and he because gold 400
prospect sells many thanks mr. beyer
answer shortly afterwards so there are certain
differences so the rare
earths were addressed that is geopolitical
because they are not so rare cobalt
is actually rare  so if you were to build car batteries at
the current level of technology
then
by 2030 you
want to reach the level that you want to achieve then the
cobalt is simply not enough so it has
nothing to do with availability because there is no
use in reciting
because  the cobalt that you have is
in batteries that are also used,
so you simply have to substitute
it, out of
sheer necessity and at the
moment when there is a market for it, so to speak
, then it will happen the
question is  only that again and again when
it comes to the topic of sovereignty next to it succeeds the
fastest what do I know best
iron phosphate battery so the tim
iron phosphate as
map material is the next step that
would be completely non-violent and with
elements you just are also easily
available and that's exactly
what it's about  it works and i think the
key to this is accelerated
material development that depends on me  t
digitization but
also with new experimental
methods and then also the
scalability at the point
so this is really a big
topic and we will see it much more in connection
with electrification in all areas of
life
hydrogen you catalysts for  end
hydrogen technology is the next
topic, even things like copper will
somehow become a topic, etc. so i
think there will be a lot of work
in this area and ultimately also a lot of
money to be made if you are fast
enough
thank you very much then we might still have time
we still have a question for a request to speak in
countries with franziska many
thanks my name is from ska
emmerling i also come from the
federal institute for material research and
test and head the
material chemistry department there in the discussion
i particularly liked this starting
point  that we really from de  r synthesis
to becoming a mechanical engineer, which for me was
already a long way off. I've been
working in Adlershof for 16 years and
I'm also at humboldt university,
so I know how well permeable it
is between non-university and
university research. my question is
in our chain  we are missing the important
links bernd mentioned real laboratories
so that's another point where we
have to sharpen it again so that
when a good result is achieved
when handing over to the next stage
in production, gaps really arise
as if we really  a good view of the
fact that we may also
have a point that should be emphasized more
to answer that i would only add a short 11
because i was addressed then i
would of course also be interested in
how the ministry sees it, for
example i think we
need these species  from real labor
and we might need
a new way like wi  r open them and
use them together because we don’t know about
some questions, for example
now just on our campus
adlershof and related it comes from
the university it comes from the look how
it comes in together it comes from
a startup and how do we manage  then
in a form of cooperation to take the
next technological step that is
simply in between and i
think that with many of these
materials that we mentioned today
we are going to be a big challenge
and we just don't have the culture
in germany that's just then  like
california, for example, maybe sooner or
later someone will really take risk capital
and there are certainly
very successful examples
there about
fraunhofer  be
because I might have
to be in my lab at the same time s
but we already work in the pilot
production and how do we create this
permeability even better and of course we
need this infrastructure
because the costs have real money
do you still want to answer that
or Frauke down the
woman character very
much like so
i saw that being addressed several times in
the current one  edge very good
developments we have so many
unicorns are the companies that
grow very quickly in a short time to just
a capital
value of more than one billion euros the sums for venture capital in
germany and europe are growing the
location is there the large investments may also be in
this way
also knocking down on the hurt
one says don't forget i find the
intensity of so proportion of
completely or in the happiness increased from 25 to
32 but hopefully they
let it go together colleagues
i find it very very exciting now
i see these breaks they will always
described again  the question i he
has she has the question is
which instruments would
simons suggest to address these gaps
that would be great
we would be happy to take up this discussion process
thank you very much
ms
formats we need and which
ones to make money from the transfer, so to speak
, we have to continue intensively we
have just spoken to the hzb yesterday
, so to speak, I was also reported on the subject
and
we do that with the other institutes, I
think that we will then, so to speak  jointly
specialized and concrete use that
is perhaps not just a question of
financial and budgetary
support but that is also a
question of what else makes this possible
le other general conditions this
week i think we haven't
reached our goal yet but i see an awareness,
so to speak, next to it transfer on the
front line at the same time concrete and asked
and we participate in that
i can only keep up to secure
and so we are capable  find
and are very interested in
supporting this further development
thank you very much madam very
briefly your comment on this I
would actually like to
say something positive at this point and the ministries from
which we always like to ask something
yes at the point also  using
an example to praise this
connectivity and also the
room and permeability beyond the
value-added stages of the
six discussing yes in the film not an easy
job back then also knew that for
a while very intensively between
the two responsible departments in the bmbf
and bmwi and that  I think it's just
the beginning that you're in the good
contacts good dialogue with each other
and that's what's happening right now so that should
also be mentioned as a big
example so that over
time the formats are then happy and
then not only time for speeches
from the audience
so matthias becker remains for
crystal growth  the anticipation is
actually already taken up on my topic
dialogue and sovereignty
are really very closely related, so to speak
, in the possibility of making
a sovereign decision for a research or
development direction
always means
knowing the partners and then seeing them accordingly
and thus
opening up possibilities  these are these are mainly
discussion groups also as you say
they are in rooms encounters and there
is of course with the among others also with the b
50 here in berlin in front of wald will be great
i think but even if it is said here
and that you also still  times
can improve in the cooperation
of the non-university
research institutions in the
perhaps also funding of
constellations that are not yet
really fundable that is
flexibility possible had
to play validity to play in such a way that we
can also advance the constellation
simply because it may make the most sense to
many  thanks matthias there is one more
speech then we'll take that as the
last row and have to come to the
end thank you so much thanks to the
villinger my name is also from the
railway i would like to address two more aspects
that have not yet been discussed in today's panel discussion - belief
but i are very
important to us it is true that firstly
the question of the selection criteria for
the technologies in which we
want to become sovereign i think that is very
important also in the global
discussion that was addressed at the beginning
and the second aspect is
when  I'll summarize that again
briefly  as i see the
strategy, science is gaining
fundamental importance
for technology sovereignty, so to speak, in
which certain branches of
science are funded in a structured way one
could almost say that science
is creating a technology there
and i had a question for woman
art and  Gentlemen, whether
a certain transformation of
science isn't necessary.
Ms. Kunst is just telling you how it basically happens in Adlershof, because ultimately
the quality of
science is not measured by the
success of a product, and
ultimately it is a publication. Thank you very
much, Mr  kraft better shortly after
the start had something to say
that i think i tried to put it in
a statement i
think as a science manager and in a
previous life scientifically i
can't claim to have made
the decision and therefore
believe  i that a broad, excellent
basic research is first of all a
prerequisite, regardless
of the application that you might
also have in mind if i
five years ago or if we believed you five years ago on the
pc from german
automotive companies we would have
stopped our battery research
because that  there won't be cell production
in germany yet we'll
buy everything in asia the train
left
maybe six years ago but it's on
the order of magnitude new giga factory
built it or something like that what i'm trying to say
is there are simply
different cycles and first of all i
think  I think that science is
still important first of
all to be excellent in oneself and then to
look at which areas and
then the interaction between
universities and non-university
ones plays a role where you work together
to then develop things very purposefully
and that  is not very difficult question how
to  selects there and certainly also
one that politics has to decide in
many places when do we
phase out coal
, do we develop technologies for afterwards
or concentrate everything for up to
8.30 p.m. these are political decisions
at which we, as
non-university people in particular
,
will or will also receive corresponding research policy specifications
thank you very much, mrs. art, please answer that yes i mean as a university we also have the right to develop ourselves confidently using the freedom of science and research as the university sees fit within the framework of its possibilities
so
maybe just do that again now  i
know that if you don't question it
, still as a statement,
so that on the one hand, broad
basic
science is essential,
on the other hand,
development must also be perceived from a
university management in
which the sciences
show that to a who  n one
does my job well he is actually
listening the essential and recognizing
which obstetrics is
actually crucial for a realignment
and what one perceives in the
natural sciences that the
borders between the disciplines
are disappearing so that
a realignment is already bottom up
and  also in orientation to the talents
that can be won in lank
but must specify
fundamental decisions, for example making
a center for
materials science is then a top-down
decision in the end that must be supported
by the colleagues in the subjects because
with them or by them  commitment is
actually certain that you say there
is, so to speak, after evaluating all the
truffle pigs that the know-
how of the future is to be applied precisely at
these interfaces so that now i
understand my profession to also rebuild structures at the
growth points of science
and de  n clearing the
way the experience with top-down
decisions so
selecting certain topics is moderately
convincing so
berlin, for example, tried that for a long time, we at humboldt university also tried this for a long time,
so that the way of
actually
listening, deciding and adapting
is the more successful one that
ultimately connects to the  answer from mr
kraft you need a broad basis you
don't know exactly what is needed at the end of the day
and yet it
needs a direction because we
can only afford a limited amount
well done for art for these great
words that switzerland also interpret as closing words
we are a bit over
at the moment that means i would like to thank all the
members of the panel for the very
committed discussions, which
did justice to this topic
, we certainly could not
address many facets, many thanks also to our
audience, you for the contributions, the
colleagues in the stream and
last but  not least many d  thanks to anja
sommerfeld from the br 50 it says that
everything was organized here and also thanks
to the edv who also supported us
with this project
thank you very much and have a successful way to berlin
[applause]
[music]